foreign
good afternoon welcome to Ways and Means
we will be having an executive session
on a number of bills but I want to alert
the audience we will not be taking up
the two last bills that are listed House
Bill 607 and house bill 445.
we are having another exact session next
Wednesday I believe we're starting at 11
A.M I will confirm that but we're just
not going to do the last two we're going
to move those off one week so we can
spend a little more time on those okay
great
yeah
okay I need a gobble
d
but before we begin we have some special
guests here today
um could you just starting at this end
of the room if you're if you're new to
Waze say hello and introduce yourself
I I'm an experienced member of ways and
I'm Janine nodder here subbing for
Dan Hines
excellent and regular members over here
and over here yes welcome
thank you madam chair I'm Lata mandipuri
rep from Nashua this is my first time on
Ways and Means and I'm subbing for
representative Malloy
welcome
and I'm representative Myrna from
Lancaster and I am filling in for
representative spilsbury
thank you for joining us today anyone
else new here no all the regular members
are here
okay with that we will open up the
executive session on House Bill 15 and
the chair will recognize representative
janigan for motion
thank you madam chair I make a motion to
retain HP 15.
is there a second
representative Olney seconds
representative janigan do you have some
comments on that yes Madam chair um I
think it's best to retain
um this bill right now while we get
additional information on
um
revenue is coming into the state and
we'll get a better idea by retaining
that and looking at it again in a little
while
we've hashed this out a lot okay great
uh if there's no other comments the
question before the committee is on the
motion of retain and the clerk will call
representative journagian yes
representative
ulery
representative dissette yes
representative merner yes the clerk
votes yes representative naughter yes
representative Saudi yes representative
orrs yes representative roachford yes
representative olami yes representative
names yes
representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy
yeah uh sorry uh benjapuria was not made
of way of you
so I've got to change all these forms
representative amendra Puti yes
representative Schoenberg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley
yes
representative Smith yes hit the vote is
19-0
oh chair yes
20-0
the vote being 20-0 to retain that the
motion carries
okay moving right along uh the next bill
we will open is House Bill 100 uh
appealing the interests and dividends
tax and the chair will recognize
representative janikian for motion thank
you madam chair I make a motion to
retain HP 100. is there a second second
represent Olney seconds
uh yes Madam chair thank you
um again I think on this bill we need a
little more time a little more analysis
and uh we will revisit
seeing none when the clerk is ready he
representative janigian
yes representative ulery
yeah
what happened with the set yes
representative murder yes representative
yes representative naughter yes
representative Saudi yes representative
orrs yes reperto virus yes
representative Army
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes representative mangaputi
yes representative Schoenberg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
alberger yes representative liply yes
representative Smith yes and the chair
yes 20-0
routine the vote being 20-0 the retain
motion passes and uh we will keep it in
uh we will now open the public the
executive session on House Bill 133
relative to repealing the communication
Services tax and the chair recognizes
representative jinnegan for motion thank
you madam chair on HP 133 I make a
motion to retain
is there a second second
representative how many seconds the
motion
would you like to speak to your motion
I would thank you madam chair
um again I think we need to a little
more information before we make a final
other comments or discussion
wow
[Laughter]
okay uh seeing none the clerk will call
the roll
representative janigian yes
representative ulery yeah yeah
representative Doucette yes
representative merner yes representative
yes representative naughter yes
representative Saudi yes representative
orrs yes representative yes
representative yes Professor Ames yes
representative Southworth yes
representative manager Puti
yes
representative Schomburg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
alberger yes representatively yes
representative Smith yes and the chair
yes 20-0
all right the vote being 20-0 the
retained motion passes we will now open
up the executive session on House Bill
192 relative to the rate and exemptions
of the interest and dividends tax and
the chair will recognize representative
janigan for motion thank you madam chair
I make a motion of retain on HP one
representative all me seconds the motion
would you like to speak to your motion
yes as um thank you madam chair as with
the other
tax bills we need some additional
information before we make a final
decision
any discussion or comments from the
committee
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
representativeian yes representative
ulery yes representative this set yes
representative merner yes representative
yes representative uh notter yes
representative Saudi yes representative
orrs yes representative or Rochford
representative Army
representative Ames yes representative
representative
yes representative Schomburg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative Leafly yes
representative Smith yes and the chair
yes 20 to zero again okay the vote being
twenty to zero the retain motion carries
okay we will now open yep sorry take
your time
turn it again
yeah sorry and follow me
retain I don't know why this wasn't
written
do another one just in case
sorry
foreign
we're going to do House Bill 220 we're
just going a numerical order
okay you all set
okay we will now open up the executive
session on House Bill 220 establishing a
committee to study the regulatory
structure of charitable gaming and the
thank you and I I move to retain house
bill 220. is there a second
and would you like to speak to your
motion a few words uh this bill is a
study bill that overlaps with a bill
that the Senate is currently uh has
actually acted on I discovered this uh
morning that it has
gone through two committees it's been
amended and it's uh now going to come to
the house uh in its amended form it
overlaps with this committee it's a it's
a commission rather than a committee but
the charge is uh overlaps but is not the
same as the committee that would be set
up under house bill 220 so I think we
need to retain in order to assess where
this one fits in and where the other one
fits in
other comments or discussion
representative could you explain to the
new members on here the difference of uh
between a commission and a committee and
how the house position would still be
maintained
um
well the uh committee is a committee
um a joint committee of the house some
Senate in this case that uh that it has
limited uh uh a limited time span to
address the responsibilities given to us
basically the life of the uh the current
session
um and it has no members other than
legislative members on it typically
anyway
whereas a commission is uh is a body
that often I think maybe always includes
additional members appointed from
outside of the legislature and has often
more a longer period
to address the issues given to it than
just the time span of the session
um and I'm sure there's an array of
commissions an array of committees that
don't exactly uh fit into the Contours
of that but that's the general idea
um and in terms of
uh well I don't really remember the
yeah I I'm assuming uh sir that by
retaining that we can still establish
position if it ever comes down to
Committee of a conference so between the
two bills so that we can if we have
something that we disagree with them on
absolutely and it's an entirely within
our control assuming the commission bill
is is sent to this committee we can make
recommendations as we see fit uh with
respect to both both bills
thank you madam chair I just wanted to
clarification for individuals that
haven't run across that yet
representative
thank you madam chair
um can you refresh my memory
representative do members of the
commission that are not part of the
I think that needs to be put into the
bill that mileage will be provided but
it usually is but I don't know whether
it usually is I shouldn't say that I I
I've seen mileage provided for uh with
with commissions but I can't speak
other comments or discussion on the
motion to retain house bill 220.
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
thank you madam chair representation yes
yes representative yes
representative merner
yes the clerk votes yes representative
naughter yes representative Saudi yes
representative orrs yes representative
roachford yes representative army yes
representative uh Ames yes
representative Southworth yes
representative minjapuri yes
representative Schoenberg yes
representative fellows yes Professor
Bolton yes representative alberger yes
representative liply yes representative
Smith yes and the chair
yes
just wanted to nothing
the vote being 20 to nothing the retain
motion succeeds and we will close the
executive session on House Bill 220.
okay now we are going to move on to
House Bill 450 so we will now open the
executive session on House Bill 450
which is relative to removing the net
operating loss deduction limit on
taxable income under the business
profits tax and the chair will recognize
representative janigan for motion thank
you madam chair I make a motion to
retain I second that motion Madam chair
okay uh motion is made to retain by
representative janigan and secondary
representative Schamberg would you like
to speak to your motion yes thank you
madam chair uh this bill needs some
additional
um work we need to look to see you know
right now there's a New Hampshire has a
10 million limit on deductions and a
10-year limit and also an 80 percent
limit on the amount that can be deducted
so we need to look at all those in more
detail and see how things will get
affected
okay seeing none the clerk will call the
roll
thank you madam chair I'm Repco janigan
yes representative Valerie
uh yes
representative yes representative merner
yes clerk votes yes representative
naughter yes representative sorry yes
representative orrs yes representative
yes representative Albany
representative Ames yes represents
Southworth yes representative Malloy
um
yes I I had prepared these in advance
but I didn't know about your
substitution
representative Schaumburg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
lburger yes representatively
yes representative Smith yes and uh
representative sandburn yes
20-0
okay the vote being 20 to zero the
retained motion passes and we will close
the public the exact session on House
Bill 450.
this is efficient okay we will now open
up the exec session on House Bill 486
relative to vehicle registrations and
reciprocal toll collection enforcement
agreements and the chair will recognize
representative ORS for a motion
thank you madam chair I'd like to make a
motion to itl this legislation is there
a second second that motion Madam chair
representative Schamberg second
representative orrs would you like to
speak to your motion
uh yes after doing my research I feel
that
House Bill 486 would harm our
constituents more than help and it would
make a tremendous change in costs we'd
we'd have to spend a lot of money
revising our system
and the information provided by DLT and
Department of Motor Vehicles DMV makes
it pretty clear that the system in place
now is very good and I think it'll be
better once the automation process is
completed
other comments on the itl motion or on
the bill
yes representative Platt one concern I
had got resolved and I initially thought
maybe the punishment didn't fit the
crime but these are Prescott laws that
have passed through tolls 10 times
before any notice is sent out then they
get all kinds of time for a second
notice and then a third notice then it
goes to the DMV and they get a uh 50 50
fine after all of that and to me that's
other comments from the committee
representative
yes thank you madam chair
um
I think we heard a lot of uh testimony
and a lot of facts over the last couple
of days on this and and I don't disagree
with a lot of it what I do disagree with
is does the punishment fit the crime uh
representative Platt just uh commented
on that and and when it comes down to it
you could you could be a chronic
offender and you could be somebody who
is ignoring the the uh notifications but
at the end of the day we could be
revoking and again I acknowledge the
fact that driving is a privilege but we
could be revoking uh somebody's
privilege to drive in New Hampshire
based on an administrative uh two dollar
or twenty dollar and five cent uh fine
that they didn't pay now we we do
restrain people and and revoke people's
ability to drive for things like drunk
driving and reckless driving
um speeding tickets paying a toll does
not rise to that level
and uh I don't think the punishment fits
the crime in this so uh I will be voting
representative Army
thank you I'd like to reiterate that
the crime in in this circumstance can uh
destroy our Turnpike fund
and our Turnpike fund keeps the
turnpikes going
uh all of the the fines as I understand
it are just about all of the revenue
that they get they have bonding
responsibilities that the state also
stands behind that
um they have to fulfill and if we
make it easy for somebody from
Massachusetts or Connecticut or Maine or
New York to to come on to our Turnpike
system and evade the tolls every single
time they come
there's going to be a lot more of that
behavior and we're going to have a much
harder time keeping our Turnpike system
solvent
and
satisfying the bond people so I think
that it's a direct attack on government
even though it's just one of a number of
them and also they don't pay because
they don't pay because they did not pay
a twenty one dollar fine they pay
because they didn't pay a twenty one
dollar fine a minimum of 10 times and it
sounds like it's more like a hundred at
other comments yes representative ulery
first point
um
defines by the Turnpike Authority aren't
not crimes they're civil penalties
um
that needs to be understood
the incidence of DWI or DUI or whatever
the hell you want to call it or speeding
those are crimes uh from a violation up
to uh class a felony depending upon what
happens as a result of the wreck
nothing in if this bill passes nothing
would change with the ability of the
Turnpike Authority to collect any
violation whatsoever other than
they would not be able to use this as a
wedge
to
revoke someone's ability to drive to use
the highway in who resides out of state
in the same parishion Massachusetts or
Maine which have a history of abuse
within their system
would not be able to revoke somebody in
ability to drive in New Hampshire for a
in another state
I know of then maybe somebody can
correct me but I know of no other type
of activity
where you can use the power of a badge
and a gun of
government
to restrict the person's ability to
drive
to make a living to take somebody to and
from
or have them as uh seize their property
without having a chance to go to civil
court and
hash it out
um
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
and to remind the vote is to itl so a
yes would be voting for itl
representative janigan yes
representative ulery
uh no
representative Doucet yes representative
merner yes representative uh plattvotes
yes representative naughter yes
representative sodi
yes representative orrs yes
representative Rochford no
representative almi
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes
representative Malloy
representative Schaumburg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative Leafly yes
representative Smith yes and the chair
yes okay it's a vote is 18 to two
okay the motion of vote of 18-2 the
motion of itl carries
uh and that will close the executive
session on House Bill 486. uh will there
be a Minority Report
foreign
on that okay let me just ask on that
because it's the only one that has a
report so far there will be one
okay well good
okay
uh representative ulery will be doing
the blurb
oh for the itl motion representative
orrs will be writing the blurb on itl
yes good okay
one more
we will now open the public excuse me
the executive session on House Bill 510
relative to removing the exemption for
premium cigars from the tobacco tax the
chair recognizes representative
roachford for a motion thank you madam
chair I'd like to make a motion in
expedient to legislate for HB 510. so
sure second representative Platt second
step
representative would you like to speak
to your motion yes thank you madam chair
so this bill HB 510 would eliminate the
current tax exemption on premium cigars
that is currently enjoyed in the state
and if the repeal was eliminated a tax
of
65.03 percent would be imposed on
premium cigars now I think it's
important to realize that the premium
cigars enjoyed a successful industry in
New Hampshire in large part because the
exemption from this this tax results in
business that comes in from neighboring
states
furthermore this business likely would
be lost uh to internet sales if the
exemption was was pulled
um
and currently only about 967 thousand
dollars is anticipated from this tax if
it were to be applied to premium cigars
representative Platt I that 967 thousand
dollars is a static analysis I think the
true number would be zero because people
will just stop all the shops would close
the business would be killed and they do
representative elberger
thank you madam chair as I understand it
and I'm happy to be corrected if I
misunderstand it this exemption was
initially put into place because
New Hampshire had an actual industry of
manufacturing hand-rolled cigars that is
no longer the case am I correct on both
okay
um given that
I look at the storefronts that I see in
Nashua where they're empty because they
have lost business
our biggest tax base
taxpay a business taxpayer in Nashua the
Pheasant Lane Mall is has lost somewhere
around a third of its
um income because of
online purchases because people are no
longer buying those things and I have a
difficult time
understanding why we are choosing this
one item
to say we want to protect
where we don't put that same kind of
effort or interest into protecting so I
yes Representatives thank you madam
chair so
my concern with this is initially when
we heard testimony there were 30 or 31
cigar
retailers in the greater Massachusetts
area when the tax came in to be
the uh
the number of retailers in the cigar
industry premium cigar industry was one
they either moved to New Hampshire or
they just went out of business and my
concern is even though it may show a
little bit of favoritism I'd hate to
kill the industry here whether it's
manufactured here or not I guess in my
opinion I hate to be driving people out
of business
seeing associate businesses surrounding
businesses take a hit financially also
and what have we done well we've okay so
now we've leveled the playing field we
put the 65 percent tax on premium cigars
but we kill it and I I hate to see
storefronts like representative alberger
is talking about just because we want to
be I don't know fair or that we they got
to take the hit because everybody else
is maybe it's time we change our
thinking and cut these other uh
retailers a break so that we don't have
empty storefronts thank you very much
representative
this is probably the umpteenth time that
this bill has come up every two years it
comes up now that doesn't I mean the
sponsor has every right to bring it up
again but after the 19th try with a zero
do you think the message will be
representative
Mommy I just like to repeat the history
of this text because it was I that
exemption
because I started it uh
it was and I had heard nothing and I
still have heard nothing except from you
that there was one place that was
rolling cigars here it is a very lowly
paid
uh occupation in
the places where it is found and and you
usually end up with a lot of asthma too
um
but on it is there because
no
no tobacco except the cigarettes were
being taxed
and they had developed these sweet
cigars which are actually uh
cigarettes without paper around them
that are very light on Tobacco and are
filled with flavors
and they developed a number of other
child friendly attractants and they were
selling them in the pharmacies right
next to the Coke or the Coca-Cola that
is not cocaine and and um
and toys
and in places where you couldn't see
they were shoplifting
so
um I was trying to get after that and I
decided to get after taxation of OTP
other tobacco products and there was a
very uh
and Veteran smoker of prime cigars on
our committee but more importantly there
was an extremely important senator who
was smoking uh
on these cigars in the Senate that had
was going to kill anything that came
over to him that uh had those attached
and that's why we put that in in the
first place but the other reason we put
it in was that not just one but for uh
tobacco sellers uh came and stood in
front of us and said we're here because
you don't have this tax if you have this
tax we're we're going on the totally on
the internet and or we're leaving the
state
and we have no means still to be able to
collect this tax from the people who go
representative
thank you madam chair and I'd also just
like to point out that
um I I do believe that um cigar bars
would start closing and let's not forget
that once that starts happening we also
are going to see a reduction in m r uh
tax from them because they're also
selling
um
drinks and some liquor and in some cases
sandwiches or whatever else they they
sell so it's gonna m r would also take a
hit
so therefore I support the itl motion
I did
I too uh wish that uh this bill didn't
keep up here in front of us but when it
does I have to do what I think I should
do which is vote against it and why do I
uh vote a
vote against the itl I should say
um
and why it's because I I believe that it
sends the wrong message that it singles
out this particular way in which tobacco
is consumed and uh says it's okay
basically it takes makes it tax-free
whereas all other uh tobacco other
tobacco being a a term of Art in this
context is subject to text this one
premium cigar is not I think it should
be we tax tobacco at a high rate for
oh sorry I Twitter fiddling with my
hands
um
but I won't repeat myself uh the
argument I've heard the argument and I
know it's uh believed by many that
somehow the way in which uh uh big
cigars are smoked uh means less goes
into your lungs or whatever and it's
less harmful I've read a lot of research
on this I
um I took my takeaway is that that's not
the case that it's harmful
um and uh and so that's my position it's
it's on the merits on the public health
aspect of this and that we shouldn't be
singling out
one particular form of uh of tobacco
packaging and exempt it from tax thank
you
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
and the motion uh before us is Ito on
House Bill
5 10. representative genegian yes
representative ulery yes representative
Doucette yes representative merner yes
the clock clerk votes yes representative
naughter yes representative Saudi yes
representative orrs yes representative
roseford yes represent Army
representative Ames no
representative Southworth no
representative uh manjapudi no
representative Schaumburg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton no
Representative no
representative leapley yes
representative
representative Smith yes representative
chair
yes okay the vote is 15 to 5.
oitl the vote being 15 to 5 the itl
motion carries on House Bill 510.
will there be a Minority Report
them
yes okay representative Ames
we'll write a Minority Report and who
will write the majority report uh
representative will you do that okay
great
okay I think
we just got done a lot of work
thank you thank you all for being here
we uh we'll close this uh executive
session and we will see you all tomorrow
at house session
and uh plan on a long day tomorrow
and then on Monday at 9 00 a.m We Will
reconvene for a public hearing on House
Bill 639 and then another public hearing
at one o'clock we will be off on Tuesday
which is town meeting day and then on
Wednesday March 15th we will reconvene
for executing whatever we have left
great travel safely and if you can get
your blurbs from everything today to me
as soon as possible the house clerk
would be very very happy thank you
foreign
[Music]